hey everyone this is kevin from the
chess website calm today were gonna be
looking at another game from day to the
2017 champions showdown the champions
showdown if you're not familiar there's
eight of the top players in the world
and each of them is matched up against
one opponent for four days and they play
30 games against that opponent mix of
rapid and blitz gesture you can imagine
30 days over four days it's gotta be
pretty fast chess first day they play
four games of 30 minute games then the
next day day two which we're gonna be
talking about today they play six games
and they each have twenty minutes to
play and then getting into the third day
they have ten minutes and they're gonna
be playing eight games and then on the
last day they'll be playing twelve games
of five minutes apiece our competitors
today white is played by Alexander
Ganesha oak his opponent playing the
black pieces
Fabiano Caruana in day one they ended up
tying as far as wins and losses both
sides did get a win on day one and then
they drew a couple games coming into day
two both of these individuals have a win
and they've tied a bunch as well so
getting into this last game of the day
game number six the 10th game so far
both sides looking to get a victory and
go into day three with a lead so we'll
go ahead and get started
Alexander gadeuk starts with pawn to d4
pawn to d5 upon c4 and then we see pawn
take on C force and not only do we not
see pawn to d4 very often we don't see
the Queens gambit very often we
definitely don't see the Queens gambit
accepted line most the time we're seeing
Queens gambit declined line but Queens
gambit accepted line and then pawn to e4
so aptly named the central variation
more common you're gonna be seeing
Knight to f3 this is the main line but
hey with with rapid style chess you
never know what you're gonna see so
Alexander gonna cook decides to play
pawn to e4 and then Knight to f6 pretty
much forces the
play of pawn to e5 and then Knight d5
Bishop takes on c4 you're always gonna
get that material back in the Queens
gambit accepted line and this brings the
knight back here to b6 Bishop comes back
here to d3 had a few options could have
played Bishop to b3 if you wanted to but
decided to play Bishop to d3 if you
haven't seen this position or if you
haven't really thought too much about
chest in general you have to be aware of
things like this where your opponent's
is playing where they they're kind of
baiting you to take here on d4 always be
looking for these this would be a trap
because Queen can't take Bishop to b5
check there's a discovered attack in the
queen is going to fall even if the Queen
comes back here to defend this he is
going to fall at the top level play
Fabiana Caruana is not gonna play and
fall into that trap but just want
everyone who's watching this to make
sure that if you see this in your own
games do not fall for this if you ever
see this in a position Knight to c6
attacking this backward pawn here on a
d4 Knight to e2 could have easily played
Knight to f3 to also protect this as
well Bishop to a g4 and essentially
needs to play pawn to f3 trying to
attack this minor piece that's defending
the square here on d4 black has both his
knights in his queen both defending this
really needs to make sure he holds on
with his night on e2 to defend the
square on d4 Caruana kicks his Bishop
back to h5 Bishop to e4 pawn a6 getting
control of the light squares and the
stern of the board also opening up the
for his dark squared Bishop to develop
then if it wants to castle on the King
side he can do that cast on the Kings
side for get it shook in and then
Caruana plays Bishop to g6 and it would
be a mistake to take this right here and
you can see that Caruana waited for
white to castle on the King side but if
the bishop were to take now the pawn
could take on GC
and this is a very strong attack that
black would have on the King side of the
board this King is already not super
safe because the pawns already pushed
forward to f3 and now with this rook on
h8 it can really start to attack his
opponent and black hasn't committed to
one side of the board this would be
different if Caruana had castled on the
King side it would be a little safer to
exchange with the bishop here on a g6
but because he has not this would
definitely be a bad exchange for
authentication if you wanted to exchange
over here hey that's that's completely
fine you could have the pawn recapture
this is gonna have double isolated pawns
on the C file that I think is completely
fine you no longer gonna have the the
bishop pair but that is an option
decided and said to play Bishop to e3
continuing his development Bishop to e7
Caruana has a few options he can castle
on the King side right away or if he
wants to he can get his queen involved
castle on the Queen side pawned a3
stopping the knight coming down to b4 or
the Bishop to b4 so both sides just
trying to kind of feel their pone it out
and see what both sides are looking to
do here Queen to d7 Knight to c3 just
simple development and then castle on
the Queen side so both sides is kind of
giddy up time and they know what they
need to do I throw everything at their
opponent's opposite side of the board
Alexander Ganesha is gonna be looking to
develop on the Queen side and Caruana is
gonna be looking to pressure the King
side of the board as far as how you
attack the Queen side of the board you
can get your Queen involved you could
play pawn to b4 if you wanted to you
have some options
this chick decides to go ahead and play
Queen to c2 which is completely fine
pawn to f5 so black looking to attack
the King side of the board and we start
to see some exchanges come off Bishop
takes on c6 Queen recaptures on c6 and
then Bishop comes back to f2 and this is
one of those where I think white could
have played a little bit more aggressive
here he had the option of Knight to f4
this allows your opponent to make a
mistake this pawn backward pawn on e6 is
only defended by the
Queen here on c6 so depending on how
black wants to continue he may not
recognize in a rapid style you don't
have as much time to think and this just
makes his opponent always weary of yeah
my my opponent has a night here on f4
and it's attacking this pawn on e6 he
doesn't really have that threat to worry
about if the bishop comes back here to
f2 so I prefer to get the knight more
involved with f4 now
pawn to f4 and we start to see both
sides really trying to have control of
this FS Foursquare Queen down to c1
Bishop to g5 now the knight takes King
over here to b8 night down here to e2
just everything going to defend the
square here Queen back here to e8 to
defend this bishop here on g6
Bishop to e3 trying to hold down the
fort here
Bishop to f5 nice little outpost move
from black rook over here to d1 says I
have a backward pawn here and since I
have everything already covering the
square here I have four I'm gonna move
my attention over to this pawn because
if things start to exchange over here I
do want to make sure that I have
something protecting this backward pawn
on d4 since my opponent is threatening
with his his rook here on d8 at this
point Caruana decides to strike first
you know we have all this material
lining up on this f4 square good
district says hey if you ever want to
take it I have three pieces that are
ready to exchange at any given time
Caruana says yeah let's go ahead and do
that I will give up my bishop pair let's
go ahead and exchange that's exactly
exactly what y it does so the bishop
takes pawn comes down here to h6 pawn
comes back III Knight d5 attacking the
bishop says okay that's fine I'll just
recapture with my queen Knight here to
c3 getting into a better spot on the
board pawn g5 started to push on the
King side of the board as we expected
from black and then we see an exchange
in the center rook takes here on a d5
but I think this is good for whites he
has a better pawn structure black has a
isolated pawn here on the e-file while
both sides have equal pawns I think the
pawn structure for white is better and
so with this I think white getting into
the endgame has a better potential to
come out with a win
you know they definitely could still tie
it's not a guaranteed win by any means
but definitely like the threats that
white has in the center of the board
pawn to h3 rook to g8 just getting ready
to push forward with his pawns here pawn
b3 Queen c7 rook here to eat a - Bishop
to g6 both sides just maneuvering a
little bit pawn a poor starting to push
on the Queen side Bishop to eat eight
trying to stop some of the push on the
Queen side of the board
Queen to a3 says hey if you want to
exchange on board I think I have a
winning in game and so let's go ahead
and do this many times especially top
level players they're not gonna do this
especially if you can look at the board
and reasonably think that they have a
good position they wouldn't exchange
their Queens unless they felt like they
had a technical win where it was just
execution it would be very difficult for
them to lose the win so in this position
Caruana says yeah I'm not looking to do
that right now so I'm gonna bring my
Queen over here to h7 pawn to b4 so
continue to push on the Queen side pawn
h5 Bishop back here f2 pawn g4 pawn
takes pawn takes back on a g4 pawn h4
and then pawn to g3 and in this I think
was a mistake on board I'm not sure that
Caruana recognized that the Queen was
here on a3 he was probably looking at
and said pawn to g3 my rook is defending
this so I think this is a great Square
and the reason I say that is white
immediately took here on g3 and then
Fabiana Caruana took a few minutes to
actually look at what to do next he
hadn't taken more than two minutes for
any move up until this entire spot and
if he really thought that this was going
to happen after he
played pawn to g3 I don't think he would
have taken too much time so just giving
up a pawn material for not really an
advantage at all I really just think
with so little time on the clock at this
point he didn't see the Queen
he thought he was starting to have a
strong attack but Bishop to g3 was a
snap move from Alexander Grichuk
it was one second on you can look and
see how long each of the moves took took
one second for him to see this so he
knew that his Queen was here on a three
even if Fabiana Caruana did not Bishop
comes to g6 pawn to b5 so you can see
White's starting to push the advantage
here Bishop f5 it is a nice little
outpost although it doesn't really do
too much right now
Queen to e3 this does centralize the
Queen I'm not sure that is the best spot
if he's trying to have the Queen hold
down this pawn on d4 I think it's better
just to play Queen to c3 just stop some
of his attacks by playing Queen 2 to e3
this is more defensive in my opinion but
rook back to d7
now decides to push forward pawn to d5
rook over here to g7 decides not to take
this I thought we might actually see the
pawn take on on d5 this does give a pawn
to black in exchange for an attack for
white to push forward with his passed
pawn he could first come over here with
rook to f1 force the bishop to move and
then push for it if he wants to with
this pawn but in the game we did not see
the pond take instead work over here to
g7 Caruana is thinking his best plan is
just to overload the King side and see
if he can have a really strong attack
and come out with a victory white
decides to continue with pawn taking on
e6 and then the bishop takes back on e6
it would be a mistake if you look at it
and say well he's overloaded the bishop
here on g3 let's just go ahead and take
that
unfortunately this rook on g8 is not
protecting the rook here the Queen can
freely take Caruana can't recapture here
the rook would come up here this would
be checkmate so while he is
double-barreling the rooks
he can't take the bishop he's forced to
take with his bishop here on e6 now rook
to a3 this is just lining up making sure
that all of his pieces are protecting
this bishop here on g3 pawn to b6 so
this is good this allows himself the
option if he ever has an exchange and
there's only one piece defending it
right now there's both the rook and the
queen but if the rook does come down to
dat doesn't fall victim to a back ranked
mate he can always bring his King here
to be seven and half safety Queen here
to F to a rook to f7 forcing the Queen
to move Queen e1 now Queen down the c2
starts to attack that rook to c1 the
Queen moves work over here to c3 just
double bearing this is exactly what you
want to do so both these rooks attacking
the square here on c7 forces the rook on
f7 to hold down the seventh ranked rook
to g7 rooked here to see two forces the
Queen and move Queen to a b4 and this is
where things get kind of crazy the rook
comes up here to c6 White has a strong
advantage but this is not the best play
a few things are happening with this the
first thing is after rook to c6 were
attacking the bishop on e6 but there's
also a discovered attack the Queen's are
now attacking each other very very huge
attack from both sides of the board but
this also opens up the door for the
Queen to take care if he if black looks
at and says okay you're attacking my
Queen here first and foremost I have to
look at that he could easily just take
with his Queen on a 4 and then whites
whites in the tough spot he would love
to take with his rook here on e6 that's
part of the reason that he was up there
but then he's just going to lose his
rook here on c2 and that's not good and
this is gonna be a game that Caruana can
easily win so the rook up here on c6 is
somewhat a mistake fortunately for Ogden
togusa
because there's not a lot of time on the
clock his mistake was overshadowed by
the even bigger mess
take and that is the rook coming down
here to g3 yes this is a free Bishop to
take here Caruana the problem is you
just lost your queen you didn't see the
queen taking here on b4 Caruana is
forced to immediately resign after this
the rook here on a c2 is protecting so
the route can't come down here down a
queen and material is always gonna be
tough to come back so Alexander Ganesha
takes the tenth and final game in day
two so going into day three the blitz
portion he has a game in hand against
Fabiana Caruana so playing a great
tournament so far Alexander Goethe shook
this has been in a fun series just the
champions showdown so far we've had lots
and lots of crazy games with so little
time for these players to think you
really start to see some some wild
strategies that you would never see in
other format so hopefully you guys are
enjoying this tournament so far and I
will see you guys in day 3 for some of
the coverage and then day 3 Magnus
Carlsen kicks off we have eight
competitors but six of those competitors
started yesterday Magnus Carlsen and
Bing Lee ins start tomorrow they will go
from Saturday to Tuesday so while we do
have four days for all the competitors
they have space it out a little bit
which will be nice that will allow me to
do more commentary over a longer period
of time so thanks for watching I'll see
you in at the next video